Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass in der 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Da läuft es langsam auf ein spannendes Saisonfinale hinaus. Deshalb wollen wir uns heute damit beschäftigen, hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 252. Hallo und herzlich Willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr hier den Rasenfunk Kurzpass eingeschaltet habt. Wir wollen heute sprechen über die 2. Männer Bundesliga. Das dürfte euch nicht mehr überraschen, wenn ihr das Intro aufmerksam gehört habt. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social. Auch das sollte euch nicht mehr so komplett vom Stuhl werfen. Aber unsere Besetzung wird euch wirklich aus dem Nichts erwischen. Denn wir haben heute wieder fantastische Gäste. Ich freue mich sehr, hier eine bekannte Stimme aus der deutschen Podcastlandschaft zu begrüßen. Tim Ecksteen ist hier vom Millan-Ton bei Twitter, auch der Tim-Ecksteen. Also denkbar einfach zu finden. Hallo Tim. Ja, schön, dass du hier bist. Schön mal zu so einem, also es ist ein günstiger Moment, würde ich sagen, dass wir miteinander sprechen. Günstiger als das letzte Mal.
Sie ist ja härter. Ihr hättet einfach nicht zu den Terminen erscheinen müssen mit Windvorost und Triple Seven und so weiter.
Also, ich mein, ein Investor will ja auch Rendite haben und wenn der merkt, der Widerstand ist zu groß, dann hat er halt keinen Bock mehr sein Geld zu verbrennen. Und dann hat er es, ich weiß aber nicht, für wie viel zurückgekauft. Der Mantel des Stillschweigens über diese Geschichte. Aber, ich meine, das ist ja trotzdem Fußballromantik pur. Ja, und wir durften, wir haben unseren Stadionnamen zurückgekauft. Das hat auch überhaupt gar keine Wellen geschlagen. Wenn das irgendjemand anders machen würde, wird es irgendwo Titelseite sein. Also, paar Sachen sind schon geil bei uns.
Woran glaubst du liegt das?
Ja, wir haben im Discord tatsächlich auch diskutiert und viele sagen halt, ja weil wir halt in diesen Klo reichen auf – also wir haben Discord-Channel für unseren Podcast. Genau. Und da haben wir diskutiert und ja, wir wissen es auch nicht so recht. Natürlich wahrscheinlich, weil wir eben zwischen den klo reichen Zeiten – 70er, 80er, 90er Jahren – von der Bildfläche verschwunden sind, so ein bisschen. Und weil wir halt noch nichts Außergewöhnliches geleistet haben, außer in die 2. Liga aufzusteigen. Aber wir sind halt noch nicht irgendwie ins Halbfinale der FW-Pokal gekommen oder haben mal die Bayern rausgeschmissen. So was brauchst du halt, glaube ich, um dann doch national bekannt zu werden.
Oder eine Relegation mit Bratpfannen kann ich auch empfehlen.
Ja, aber da sagst du es wieder. Ja, ich meine, bei der Relegation gegen 60 haben die 60er die Allianz Arena zerstört und sind dann rausgeschmissen worden.
Da habe ich gestern noch drüber nachgedacht. Ohne Witz. Wie hieß denn nochmal, wer stand denn da im Tor, der so total ruhig geblieben ist, als die Stangen geflogen sind bei Regensburg?
Philipp Pentke, der jetzt bei Hoffenheim in der Champions League gespielt hat, oder?
Das weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr. Philipp Pentke. Gestern habe ich mich mit jemanden drüber unterhalten und da habe ich noch drüber gesprochen, wie irre das war, dass eben damals diese ganzen Plastikstangen geflogen sind und Sitzschalen auch. Der ist halt einfach so Richtung Strafraumkante gegangen und der Schiedsrichter hat ja dann irgendwann dieses Spiel einfach weiterlaufen lassen, weil er wollte, dass dieses Spiel vorbeigeht. Ich glaube, er hat sich einfach darauf verlassen. Philipp Pentke wird schon von nichts getroffen und er bleibt jetzt cool, weil er war die ganze Zeit so, naja, was soll da schon passieren? Ein bisschen Plastik.
Er hat ja auch gemeint, er hat im Osten Fußball spielen angefangen, da gab es viel schlimmere Spiele oder so.
Stimmt, genau, der war wirklich total ruhig. Aber jetzt, um nochmal ganz kurz in die Gegenwart dann zurückzukommen, abschließend, also aktuell ein Punkt Vorsprung auf die Abstiegsplätze. Logischerweise ist damit aber noch bei Weitem nicht alles entschieden. Man spielt gegen alle Teams, die aktuell noch hinter einem stehen bzw. hinter die Letzten platzierten. Gegen die spielt man noch. Also in Sandhausen, die aktuell 18. sind, in Rostock, die aktuell 17. sind, auch nacheinander, das wird Ende April, Anfang Mai der Fall sein, und am vorletzten Spieltag in Braunschweig, die aktuell Tabellen 16. sind. Wir wissen jetzt natürlich nicht, ob das auch noch in der Konstellation dann so sein wird, aber alle aktuell direkten Konkurrenten auswärts. Wie blickst du auf euer Restprogramm?
Ja, mit gemischten Gefühlen, weil irgendwie ist natürlich irgendwie am besten, wenn man gegen irgendwelche Leute spielt, die halt, oder gegen Mannschaften spielt, die jetzt nichts mehr zu gewinnen oder verlieren haben am Ende der Saison. Aber dass wir es noch selber in der Hand haben, glaube ich, ist schon ein Vorteil, vor allem jetzt, wo wir wieder so ein bisschen psychisch auf der Höhe sind. Es darf halt nichts passieren bei uns, es darf singen nicht kaputt gehen, es darf OVUSO nicht kaputt gehen und keiner aus der Viererkette darf ausfallen. Das ist halt genau meine Sorge, egal gegen wen es dann geht. Also am besten eben verletzungsfrei und dann glaube ich nicht, dass wir absteigen, weil die Spielanlage mit der Stammelf zu gut ist. Und ich hoffe, dass wir spätestens in Sandhausen so in Anführungsstrichen klar machen mit einem Sieg. Da gibt es auch einen Sonderzug, der zweite Sonderzug in unserer Geschichte, der jetzt hundertprozentig stattfindet, weil die 500 Plätze verkauft sind. Sehr gut. Genau, wir haben einen Hypetrain und Respekt an die Ultras, dass sie es organisiert bekommen haben, weil ein Haufen Arbeit, so ein Sonderzug. Und ich hoffe, dass wir dann in Sandhausen quasi das zu einem Heinspiel machen und dann gewinnen. Und dass es dann dann so ein bisschen um ist. Aber das ist natürlich ein Traum. Aber wenn es am Ende mit der Relegation irgendwie klappt und wir drin bleiben, unterschreibe ich es auch. Hauptsache noch mal ein Jahr 2. Liga mindestens.
Da wäre ja vielleicht auch bei all diesen Kaderumstrukturierungen jetzt auch recht hilfreich, wenn man eben so viele auslaufende Verträge hat, dass man dann wenigstens verlängern könnte oder andere Spieler holen, die dann in die 2. Liga wollen und nicht in die 3.
Früher habe ich immer gesagt, quasi der Aufstieg in die 2. Liga ist ein Jahr Nicht-Abstieg, 3. Liga und DFB-Bokal-Qualifikation. So sehe ich es jetzt auch so ein bisschen. Wenn wir das nächste Jahr wieder schaffen, sind wir wieder ein Jahr und ein Schritt weiter. Wieder 2-3 Millionen Euro mehr fürs Nachwuchsleistungszentrum. So bodenständig würde ich das jetzt versuchen zu sehen.
Und wie es genau wird, das wird ja dann Tobias Werner in 1889 FM dann erzählen. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf dein Interview. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Das hat großen Spaß gemacht. Zwischendurch hat Tim mich noch geschockt mit der Fake News, dass Julian Nagelsmann entlassen ist. Aber offenbar gibt es einen Artikel, den ich jetzt nacharbeiten muss. Ich habe das alles nicht mitbekommen. Aber solange Selim Begovic bei Jan Regensburg bleibt, dann wissen wir, entweder es gibt niemanden, der ihn feuern kann oder die Welt ist noch in Ordnung. Und mit Frank Schmidt muss ich jetzt ja gar nicht anfangen. Das ist ja sowieso die Konstante des Profifußballs. Vielleicht schaffe ich auch irgendwann nochmal, mein Interview mit ihm zu bekommen. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Ich danke Petra Neher, der Adfrau-Näher auf Twitter. Schreibt ihr dort – und das ist jetzt der erste Zweitliga Kurzpass, wo du nicht noch die Heidenheimer Perspektive ausführlich im Vor- und Nachliefer musst. Nee, danke dir, dass du hier warst, Petra. Und herzlichen Dank an Tim Ecksteen vom Millantoon. Den kennt ihr natürlich alle unter tim-ecksteen. Kann man ihnen auch auf Twitter folgen. Danke dir, lieber Tim, dass du hier warst und mich sogar über die 1. Bundesliga auf dem Laufenden gehalten hast.
Der reale und nicht nur der Hypetrain, sondern auch der reale Sonderzug des FC St. Pauli fährt dieses Jahr übrigens nach Heidenheim.
Einfach was?
Normalerweise ist es immer am letzten Spieler oder zum letzten Auswärtsspieler, aber das ist jetzt dieses Jahr nun mal nach Kiel. Da wurde dann entschieden, über das ein bisschen kurz, um den Partywagon im Sonderzug hochleben zu lassen. Deswegen fährt er jetzt nach Heidenheim. Ja, er ist schon an vielen anderen Standorten angekommen. Ich kann da vom Innenleben berichtet man immer nicht, aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr, sehr schöne Angelegenheit.
Wir werden es beobachten. Das ist dann am 8. April das Topspiel Heidenheim gegen St. Pauli. Das haben wir ja vorhin schon angesprochen. Und herzlichen Dank auch an Robert Fischer, der uns mal hier eben schön durch die komplette Geschichte diesen Jahren durchgeführt hat. Danke, Robert, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk warst. Ja, jederzeit gerne. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das war's mit diesem Kurzpass. Gebt uns gerne Feedback, wie er euch gefallen hat. Auch dieses neue Format ist ja vielleicht auch gerade in der Länderspielpause dann gar nicht so schlecht. Es ist ein bisschen zeitloser zu halten. Ihr könnt den Rasenfunk unterstützen auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club erfahrt ihr wie. Und ihr könnt hier im Kurzpass natürlich auch noch andere Folgen hören. Wir haben über den letzten Frauen-Bundesliga-Spieltag gesprochen. Wir werden auch über den nächsten Frauen-Bundesliga-Spieltag sprechen. Und in der Schlusskonferenz geht es natürlich mit der Männer-Bundesliga weiter. Und die europäischen Top-Ligen haben wir auch noch, das dann wieder im Kurzpass. Und Tribüngespräche gibt es auch. Also euch wird nicht langweilig werden, auch jetzt in der Pause. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, bleibt gesund. Bis bald, hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.